wusstet ihr eigentlich dass Angela
Merkel den partei-namen Alternative für
Deutschland quasi erfunden hat zu
beschließenden Hilfen für Griechenland
sind alternativlos erfunden das stimmt
nicht so ganz aber sie hat sehr viel mit
dem Partei Namen zu tun und mit der
Gründung der Partei es gibt überhaupt
nichts auf der Welt was wirklich
alternativlos ist das war Bernd Lucke
der hat die AFD mitgegründet war auch
erstmal ihr Vorsitzender ist
mittlerweile aber Geschichte der wurde
ziemlich schnell gegangen laufen aber
tut es für die AFD und zwar ziemlich gut
quasi als Geschenk zum 10 geburtstag
kann sich die Partei über 15% im
aktuellen Politbarometer freuen das sind
5% Punkte mehr als bei der letzten
Bundestagswahl und mehr als FDP und
Linke im Moment zusammenholen würden in
Thüringen wo die AFD sowieso immer schon
stark war stellt sie immer wieder neue
umfrage-recorder auf im Moment liegt sie
vorne die jetzige afd-chefin bittert
schon macht morgen Luft nach zehn Jahren
sind wir bereits die stärkste Kraft in
Ostdeutschland dass wir dort auch
durchstoßen mit einer realistischen
regierungsperspektive rein rechnerisch
ist das natürlich total realistisch nur
hat die AFD ein ganz dickes Problem sie
veraltet sich ausgerechnet mit ihrem
Erfolgsrezept ihr erklärtes Ziel nämlich
mit zu regieren um diese Sackgasse geht
es in unserer neuen Folge von
inside-politics und erklären möchte ich
euch das gerne indem wir uns mal die AFD
im Wandel der Krisen der letzten Jahre
anschauen mit der Euro-Krise fangen wir
an ich bin Nicole Diekmann arbeite im
ZDF-Hauptstadtstudio und Berichte
regelmäßig über die AFD die selbst
ernannte Alternative für Deutschland
herzlich willkommen
Griechenland Krisensitzungen Streit
Rettungsschirme Troika 2013 ist geprägt
von der Euro-Krise und da gründet sich
eine neue Partei die AFD denn Angela
Merkels Aussage über die angebliche
Alternativlosigkeit hatte viele
irritiert alternativlos wurde sogar zum
Unwort des Jahres 2010 alternativlos
ersticke den politischen Diskurs
begründete die Jury ihre Entscheidung es
suggeriere es gäbe keinen Platz für
Diskussionen viele wollten aber
diskutieren über den Euro über die
schlechte wirtschaftliche Lage in
Ländern wie eben Griechenland und
darüber warum zum Beispiel Deutschland
also der Steuerzahler bei der Rettung
einspringen sollte für solche Fragen
aber wahr jedenfalls hatten nicht wenige
das Gefühl eben kein Platz das damals
zum Beispiel auch in der SPD so erstmal
muss man die sorgen nicht nur ernst
nehmen sondern muss es erklären und das
ist ein Versäumnis vor allem auch der
derzeit Regierenden die Entscheidung
nicht richtig erklärt zu haben diesen
angeblich fehlenden Platz für
Diskussionen Schuft dann eben die AFD
deshalb als ein themenpartei betrachtet
wurde als die antie-europartei das Thema
Euro ist mittlerweile längst in den
Hintergrund gerückt da ist die AFD
flexibel eins aber ist ihr geblieben ihr
Wesenskern als Partei die anders sein
will als die anderen die Kompromisse
ablehnt die AFD tritt unversöhnlich auf
die AFD sagen viele ist die
dagegenpartei die Partei der Angstmacher
spielen sie denn da nicht mit den
Hoffnungen und mit den Ängsten der
Bürger können Sie denn versprechen dass
alles besser wird wenn man aus der
Eurozone Austritt also so schlimm wie es
zur Zeit ist kann sie wohl keine
Perspektive sein zu sagen wir lassen
einfach alles so übrigens auch damals
schon eindeutig zu hören Rechte bis
rechtsradikale Töne auch das hier ist
Bernd Lucke auch 2013 meine Damen und
Herren wir haben so viel an
Entartungen von Demokratie und
Parlamentarismus in der in den letzten
vier Jahren erlebt entartet das ist ein
Begriff der die Nationalsozialisten für
ihre Rassenlehre verwendeten und mit
solchen Gedanken gut trat ganz zu Beginn
sogar einer der Gründerväter der AFD in
Erscheinung auch wenn der nicht lange in
der Partei durchgehalten hat
Multikulti gehen führt zu Mutationen und
damit zu Krankheiten die vorher bei
Reinrassigkeit nicht vorhanden waren
wissenschaftlich erwiesen so viel also
zur Eurokrise da war die AFD noch jung
und nur so Mittel erfolgreich aber dann
kam die Flüchtlinge
[Musik]
die nächste große wirklich große Krise
beginnt spätestens 2015 in Syrien
herrscht Krieg viele Menschen flüchten
vor Bomben und Terror auch aus
Afghanistan dem Irak und aus anderen
Ländern machen sich viele auf den Weg
viele kommen in die EU sehr viele von
ihnen wollen nach Deutschland Bilder
gehen um die Welt von großen
Menschenmassen von boten die sich den
Weg über das Mittelmeer nach Europa
Bahnen und von Ländern wie Ungarn die
Zäune Bauen von Menschen die über die
Grenze nach Deutschland kommen und von
Protesten nicht nur aber vor allem im
Osten Deutschlands es wird in der
Politik wenig diskutiert aus Sorge dass
die Debatte kippt und von Rechtsaußen
gekapert wird aber genau das passiert
paradoxerweise gerade durch das
Schweigen der neben dem konkreten Thema
dem Thema Flüchtlinge entsteht ein
zweites ein narrativ und das lautet die
da oben die schweigen weil sie uns etwas
verschweigen als der öffentliche Druck
dann sehr sehr hoch wird sagt Angela
Merkel doch etwas
nämlich diesen mittlerweile berühmten
Satz wir haben so vieles geschafft wir
schaffen das nur wie wir das schaffen
das erklärt sie nach Ansicht vieler
immer noch viel zu wenig aus dieser
Stimmung heraus erlebt die 2014
gegründete rechtsradikale pegida
massiven Zulauf pegida steht für
patriotische Europäer gegen die
Islamisierung des Abendlandes Woche für
Woche sammeln sich vor allem in Dresden
immer mehr Menschen die von zum Teil
sehr lauten und sehr radikalen Rednern
aufgepeitscht werden das ist die Stunde
der AFD die dümpelt in diesem Sommer
2015 eigentlich nur noch so vor sich hin
kurze vor hat sie beim Lücke vom Hof
gejagt und mit ihm zusammen haben
tausende Mitglieder die AFD verlassen
die Partei steht also kurz vor dem Ende
kratzt an der 5% Hürde und zwar von
unten dann aber schnell die Zahl der
Asylanträge in die Höhe und die AFD
springt abermals in eine kommunikative
Lücke die die anderen Parteien ihr
gelassen haben und sucht den
Schulterschluss mit pegida die
anti-partei geht gemeinsam auf die
Straße mit Ihnen die gegen eine
sogenannte Islamisierung sind und greift
dort große Massen ab da ist es das
Muster hier wird es zum ersten Mal
wirklich deutlich wie schon beim Thema
Euro setzt die AFD auch jetzt auf
Angstmache und auf Radikalität auf
scharfe Abgrenzung zu den anderen
Parteien und auf scharfe Rhetorik es
hatte ja schon zu Beginn erster
Anzeichen gegeben für rechte Tendenzen
in der AFD und die rechnen jetzt voll
auf einige der in diesen Jahren
getätigten Aussagen werden sie später
dann auch in Berichten des
bundesverfassungsschutzes wiederfinden
das deutsche Volk wollen diese Menschen
die überwiegend umgebildet
jung männlich und muslimisch sind gar
nicht integriert die Strategie zieht 16
Prozent im Osten würden AFD wählen wird
das Meinungsforschungsinstitut for sah
Ende 2015 melden der stellvertretende
afd-chef Alexander gauland nennt die
flüchtlingskrise dann auch in einem
Interview ein Geschenk für seine Partei
gauland setzte konsequenterweise dann
auch immer und verholender auf
Radikalität 2016 schreckt er auf einer
Kundgebung in Elsterwerda in Brandenburg
schon nicht mal mehr davor zurück einen
alten Slogan der NPD zu zitieren und
zwar gleich mehrfach heute sind wir
tolerant und morgen fremd im eigenen
Land und wenn ich das anspreche und
ausspreche dann habe ich nicht gesagt
dass es gut ich stelle es fest es ist
das was die Deutschen Bewegungen heute
sind wir tolerant und morgen fremd im
eigenen Land direkt hinter gauland ihr
habt es wahrscheinlich schon längst
erkannt stehen wir ein Höcker und
Andreas Kallwitz der inzwischen zwar
nicht mehr in der AFD ist aber trotzdem
immer noch sehr gut dort vernetzt Kalbes
und höcke gelten mittlerweile als
gesichert rechtsextremistisch und werden
deshalb seit einigen Jahren vom
Verfassungsschutz beobachtet und das
nicht nur im Rahmen ihrer politischen
Arbeit das passiert nicht so oft und
zeigt für wie potenziell gefährlich der
Verfassungsschutz die beiden hält das
Kalkül geht auf 2017 zieht die AFD
erstmals in den Bundestag ein und wird
als Fraktion mit den meisten
Abgeordneten in der Opposition sogar zum
Oppositionsführer
[Musik]
dann kommt 2020 und damit kommt Corona
erst tut sich die AFD ein bisschen
schwer damit eine einheitliche Haltung
zu finden aber die anderen Parteien
machen es ihr wieder relativ leicht
weder tut sich eine Lücke auf die
Bundesregierung in der ersten und
massiven corona-phase war das ja noch
die große Koalition unter Merkel ist
sich in vielem weitestgehend einig und
verlangt zum Teil wirklich krasse
Maßnahmen Lockdown Schulze keine großen
Gruppen eine Zeit lang das wirkt jetzt
schon wieder ganz schön weit weg aber
das war ja so durften wir einander ja
sogar nur abgezählt zu Hause besuchen
das war schon heftig und in den meisten
Punkten herrschte da trotzdem Einigkeit
zwischen Regierung und Opposition das
ist auch nicht allzu überraschend denn
auch wenn sich manches im Nachhinein als
Fehler rausstellen sollte argumentieren
und entscheiden die meisten in dieser
Zeit ja auf Grundlage wissenschaftliche
Erkenntnisse wieder also große
Geschlossenheit wenig offene Kritik also
wieder eine Lücke in die die AFD
springen kann und in die die AFD dann
auch springt der Einzelhandel kommt zu
mal liegen auch die Innenstädte werden
verweisen und immer mehr wird verlagert
auf online bestellformate und deshalb
lehnen die afd-fraktion diesen Lockdown
ab was auch dieses Mal passiert genauso
wie schon während der flüchtlingskrise
die AFD sucht den Kontakt zur Straße
einige Funktionäre laufen mit bei den
corona-protesten Schulterschluss mit
sogenannten Querdenkern von denen
inzwischen einige entweder ins Ausland
geflohen oder aber verhaftet worden sind
in dieser Phase erklärt der
Bundesverfassungsschutz denn auch dass
er die gesamte AFD als rechtsextremen
Verdachtsfall beobachtet dem Erfolg der
AFD kann das wenig anhaben sie zieht
wieder in den Bundestag ein wenn auch
mit weniger Mandaten und ihre
Erfolgsserie bei Landtagswahlen wird
gestoppt im Großen und Ganzen aber hält
sich die Partei stabil
[Musik]
Deutschland 27 Februar 2022 der
Bundestag debattiert über den russischen
Angriff auf die Ukraine an diesem Tag
setzt
afd-chef-scholz sie haben heute leider
den Kalten Krieg reaktiviert mit ihrer
Rede das muss ich so deutlich sagen
und wir müssen fragen welche sozialen
Folgen hat ihre Politik für die
deutschen Bürger diese müssen schon
jetzt überall mit steigenden Preisen
leben lernen Stichworte Benzinpreise
Heizkosten steigende Inflation wollen
sie allen Ernstes die Bundesregierung
sein die wir Soldaten in einen Krieg
gegen Russland schickt das Leben wir
eben so ab wie die Lieferung von Waffen
in Kriegsgebiete unser Land zuerst und
eine tiefe Sympathie für Russland den
Kriegstreiber das kennzeichnet die AFD
damit hat sie ein Alleinstellungsmerkmal
im Deutschen Bundestag nur Teile der
Linkspartei argumentieren ähnlich aber
anders als bei der AFD herrscht darin
bei der Linken keine Einigkeit wieder
ist die AFD also dagegen gegen
Sanktionen gegen Russland gegen
Panzerlieferungen unsere
ich sitze nicht in Moskau unsere Feinde
sitzen in Washington nur in Berlin und
dieses Mal ist die Abgrenzung zu den
anderen Parteien noch schärfer als sonst
weil eben so viel Einigkeit darin
besteht dass die Ukraine im Kampf gegen
den Aggressor Russland unterstützt
werden muss ihr habt die Zahlen am
Anfang ja gesehen dieses
Alleinstellungsmerkmal verfängt ganz
offensichtlich die AFD steht in den
Umfragen gut da der Grund dafür dass sie
so gut da steht ist aber auch Ihr
Problem und damit kommen wir zum Fazit
und zu meiner Einschätzung warum die AFD
an ihrem eigenen Erfolgsrezept scheitert
[Musik]
die AFD will anders sein als die anderen
Parteien und die AFD ist auch anders nur
wie ich euch gerade gezeigt habe ist sie
das aus Prinzip es scheint ihr völlig
egal worum es inhaltlich geht diese
Inszenierung als fundamental-opposition
wird noch dadurch verstärkt dass
Vertreter der AFD demokratische Werte
und Institutionen immer wieder und
völlig unverblümt in Frage stellen der
Kampf den wir kämpft um die Existenz
unserer Nationen und Europas der wird
nicht in den Parlamenten entschieden der
wird tatsächlich auf der Straße
entschieden durch solche Äußerungen
macht sich der AFD als regierungs-
die AFD selber sagt immer wieder
eigentlich käme nur die CDU in Frage als
Koalitionspartner und ja auf kommunaler
und auch auf Landesebene gab es da in
den vergangenen Wochen und Monaten immer
mal wieder gemeinsame Abstimmungen aber
die Brandmauer zu AFD ist immer wieder
klar von der CDU-Spitze kommuniziert
worden der bloße Blick auf die Zahlen
nutzt also nicht sehr viel da müsste die
AFD bei Wahlen schon dermaßen abräumen
dass sie übrigens Parteien keine
Koalition und seien sie noch so bunt
mehr ohne die AFD hinbekommen würden was
glaubt ihr lässt sich dieser Kurs der
AFD durchhalten oder wenden sich die
Anhänger irgendwann von ihr ab weil es
eben keine realistische Machtperspektive
gibt oder aber verlässt die AFD
irgendwann die fundamentalistische
Haltung und wird realpolitische und
dadurch anschlussfähiger ist es
überhaupt noch möglich Stichwort
Verfassungsschutz wir freuen uns wenn
Ihr darüber in den Kommentaren
diskutiert uns ein Like da lasst
natürlich auch Kritik und uns abonniert
bis zum nächsten Mal